i grew up with superman i know superman
well i watched the television shows i
read the comics and the only thing i
would say is it is a european fantasy
to think that superman would want to
meet beethoven
when you talk about
america and civilization or this western
civilization
the american attitude was not that
europe needed to be saved because of
civilization but that civilization
needed to be saved from europe
this was
this was the reaction and so
when you talk about the american
attitude towards civilization americans
after world war ii people like dean
atchison people like harry truman and
owen
thought europeans could not be trusted
only the united states could be trusted
to keep peace but aimana emphasized not
keep this civilization america doesn't
have a civilization america piggybacks
on top of the european civilization and
americans don't forget our parochial
and the the introduction to the superman
television show which i watched as a
child over and over again always said
that superman came to earth with powers
and abilities far beyond those immortal
men and what he was doing was fighting
for truth
justice and the american way
he was not fighting for the united
nations he was not fighting for
international peace he was not fighting
for beethoven and so the american nation
the american people have this
peculiarity and i'll end with this point
the funny thing about americans they are
not isolationists because embedded in
their dna in their founding documents is
an internationalist principle the
principle of universal rights it's the
enlightenment principle
but at the end of the day americans have
felt that they are the only ones who can
be trusted to carry out these principles
and so they don't have this sense of
empathy and feeling about what you've
been talking about today in terms of
this civilization
well
as you can see there is a
huge difference
between europe and the us
and i believe bob is right
superman
is an american hero
and being an american hero superman
looks always
to
what catastrophe
superman can solve
that means
there is a direct link
between superman
and
the situation of the world and the
catastrophe
that superman can answer to
the problem is today that sometimes
superman do create
catastrophe
so i want to thank bob
for the subprime crisis
for the fall of lemon brother
for the triumph of goldman sachs
for iraq for iraq for afghanistan
and i believe
if it is true that there is no american
civilization i think we need to build
one
we need to find a common answer between
europe and the us in order to avoid
those catastrophes that unfortunately
are creating not superman
but frankenstein
and
a frankenstein in the west can create
superman
in the east
berlin is a superman
in many countries in many mind of people
in the east
and in many ways
the big superpower the big high power of
the us
which is to my mind a pure myth
but has contributed
by
a certain vision of the world
to create many of the problems we are
facing today because yes there is
in our culture in the way we deal with
life a very strong difference with the
us the u.s are looking forward always
whatever problem whatever difficulty
they are looking forward looking to the
future they have this great capacity to
invent
and to never feel defeated by anything
they look forward
we the europeans we are torn apart by
and puzzled by our own anxiety by the
feeling that
we may
we
knew with
the difficulties of the past we are
hunted by ghosts
but at the same time we have something
which is of
very big value
we have
a creative in satisfaction
we are not satisfied by the way the
world and by the way europe
is we want to change it
and in some ways we have still the
spirit
of revolution alive in our blood we do
feel that we can do better we don't feel
that we are yet and this is
we'll say an american concept we are not
yet at the end of history there's
something else to be done
and something else with that cannot be
about by dollars that could not be
just materialized
but that mean that man can be better
than what it is this is still
the biggest challenge of today but i
want to
give the floor to my neighbor
you can see what a difficult job i have
you have is two brilliant
eloquent
scholars and statesmen
and in between you have a simple humble
asian
and
and and i'm going to do what all uh
simple humble asians do
uh which is to begin with an apology
and the apology is that i'm afraid i'm
going to be saying some
somewhat uncomfortable things
for all of you
but the reason why i have to say
many of these uncomfortable
things because for those of you who live
in the west whether it exists or not
as far the rest of the world is
concerned there is a west
the world that is coming
in the next 10 to 20 years
and dominic was hinting at that
will be a difficult
uncomfortable one
and it's in some ways
a result
partly of demographics
they're about 6.8 6.9 billion people in
the world
about eight to 900 million people live
in europe america australia canada in
the west
and about 6 billion live roughly outside
these six billion people
have essentially been passengers
on the bus of history for a few hundred
years
now
they no longer want to be passengers
and they want to be co-drivers with the
west
in moving world history forward
and as they
want to do so
they
recognize and i want to emphasize this
both the strengths
and the beauty rob
of western civilization
but they also recognize
and are equally aware of the ugly side
of western civilization
while i want to take you out of your
comfort zones
i do want you to know that the world
that is coming
is a happy one
you may not believe this
and the reason why it's a happy one
is because of your gift of modernity
there are going to be
one or two billion people
joining the middle classes
in the next decade or two
and guess what
this one or two billion people won
they want to live just like you and they
want to come to events like this
and have time to relax and worry about
the future of the world and not worry
about the next meal whether it's going
to come there not thank you
let's not talk about so much as we have
here
the superiority the superior sensibility
of the european the superior sensibility
and harmony of the asian
uh we are going to be dealing and the
world to come with the very traditional
and also painful realities
of international life that we've been
dealing with for quite some time
now my personal view
is that we will deal with it better
to the degree that those of us who share
the universal values that is the
inheritance of the western civilization
do stick together